[Music]
hello hello hello hello hello how's
everybody doing how're you feeling how
you live and how you move in it is the
week of April 15th coming to you on
Tuesday April 16th and we got the bad
man back Bart Scott will be in the
building for around an hour and a half
probably more you guys wanted them back
yeah got him so I'm happy to have them
in store just want to do a quick intro
I'm recording this on Monday heading
down to Atlanta to do the some MBA
Twitter show so if you're ever watching
NBA playoff games go onto Twitter and
I'm probably on there talking about the
game I'm gonna lose my mind if the
Sixers go down Oh - if you watch the
Masters this past weekend unbelievable I
cried I did when he hugged this when he
hugged his son when Tiger hugged his son
I shed a tear for those of you that
watched that that was enjoyable for
those of you that like Game of Thrones
that was awesome amazing to have it back
I watched a lot I watched that I watched
Barry and I watched that show
action on Showtime it's a four-part
DocuSign blowing in America and I'm
going to try and get more people on if
you've seen it you saw that Warren
Sharpe our buddy is in it episode three
you knew else's in Episode three me and
Sims there's like right after they show
the Todd Gurley slide and there you hear
me go but this the line was seven and a
half and Sims goes [ __ ] the line and
that was our appearance in the
docu-series action so that was a lot of
fun to check out this weekend I only
have one other story when I get to
because I want to get right to Bart but
I do want to answer a reddit question
thank you to the people of Reddit the
the people that have helped build the
left ghost show on reddit go check it
out I'm gonna answer one question from
there a week and I figured you know what
let me do this now cuz I didn't get to
it last week
reddit question from Jim underscore
Tomsula and I think it's a goodie
would you rather fight one Trent
sighs Trent Taylor or 100 Trent Taylor
sized Trent Browns first of all apology
- Trent Taylor being used in that regard
I would rather fight 100 Trent Taylor
sized Trent Browns mr. Jim underscore
Tomsula because if Trent Taylor was the
size of Trent Brown he would destroy the
universe
but you guys witnessed Retton Brown in
this chair my man is relaxed my man's
feeling good and I think we have a good
relationship so it would just be me on a
mountain of Trent Brown's kicking it I
know his demeanor I think we'd be fine
but one super-sized Trent Taylor I would
be deathly afraid for my life the only
other story that really really really
caught my eye before we get to Bart
Scott yes by the way later in this week
we're gonna hear from Kentucky pass
rusher Josh Allen who might be going in
the top five and we had a really good
conversation about how he could maybe be
a wide receiver in the NFL that's coming
up on Thursday but Russell Wilson and
this started a few months ago a few
weeks ago when Colin Cowherd said that
he really thought that he wanted to be
in New York and that was I even said at
the time what was Colin Cowherd doing
trying to break news it was fleshed out
more by Pro Football Talk that Seattle
is apparently saying they believe that
Russell Wilson doesn't want to be there
and wants to be in New York and I think
what we can start to do is start to use
our big boy journalist hats and start
doing what we've always talked about on
this show and not pay attention to the
news but pay attention to how it's being
delivered and who's putting it out
little quick thought before we get to
Bart Scott Seahawks put out this story
the way it's being reported - it's the
Seahawks organization number one is that
John Schneider the GM is that B Carroll
the head coach is it a waterboy
is it an assistant is it a secretary
let's look at that
the Seahawks organization number two who
put out the story
the Seahawks why would that benefit them
because it puts Russ in a Dakini in a
situation where he has two decisions
either he doesn't address it and then
the fans go do you want to be here and
they eat you turn the fans against him
because then if you don't sign him he
didn't to be here anyway or he comes out
and he says I want to stay to which the
fans are gonna go will then sign the
contract they're offering you the
Seahawks are putting pressure through
the media on Russell Wilson by saying he
wants to be in New York because what's
the fear of every franchise in every
sport you're gonna turn us down and go
to the big city you're gonna leave New
Orleans for the Lakers like Anthony
Davis everybody wants the glitz and the
glamor in New York is an amazing city to
get your fanbase angry at by saying that
your star player actually prefers to
play there they're not blue-collar
they're New York Russel Wilson I also
think it's even more so the whole Ciara
thing oh he's just doing this because of
his wife lets him in if you see the
pictures that I put on the Left go show
IG about what Russell Wilson looked five
years ago compared to now he's a
different man and frankly if he's able
to come to New York that would be great
he's got Russell Wilson he's got the
Seahawks right where Kirk Cousins had
Washington right now he slated to earn
if he gets franchise the next two years
66 million dollars over the next two
years that's 33 year that's still less
than what Rodgers is making but over the
next three he slated to make 118 and so
we're about to see if the Seattle
Seahawks are going to go down a Kirk
Cousins road and keep franchise tagging
or if they're gonna give them a contract
that's worth that amount of money or
they're gonna trade them that's what's
gonna happen
and I believe that they're setting the
tone early through these stories that
they're leaking by trying to diminish
Russell Wilson's leverage and also get
their own fan base to start thinking why
would I wait for a guy why would I root
for a guy that doesn't even want to be
here so don't get caught up in the mess
always remember people are reporting the
stories and people are fickle let's get
to Bart Scott bringing the energy it's a
blast
everything from Bill Belichick and how
bard almost wanted to fight him to what
it was really like to be under Rex Ryan
to the one coach that he thinks isn't
even smart enough to coach to a lot of
[ __ ] talk let's check in with the me in
Bart Scott you heard the voice he is
back in the building
he's back on the map it is Bart Scott
what took so damn long man they needed
you they wanted you back to the homies
needed you I'm not even making you sign
a contract this time you're back now I'm
good I'm hoping this could be the trust
tree man it is the trust tree how you
feeling I'd like to see I'm feel great
man I can't complain too cool it with
Donna man I'm wearing this sweater not
on purpose but I'm gonna say it's
because it's black and yellow and white
because the Steelers are [ __ ] taking
over this offseason this is insane
what the hell is going on with your
former rival man I don't know man it's
like the inmates are running the asylum
yeah I don't know man this is a lot of
turmoil they gotta figure that place out
because under the underneath all
everything that's going on they're in a
division that has now become a tough
division trying to be taken over by some
young blood yeah think about Baker
Mayfield yes yeah he got some weapons to
help him you know to compete for that
division and now you have you know Lamar
Jackson bringing in Earl Tommy's
bringing in some type of like veteran
leadership they're retooling they have a
good draft pick and the Stiller's are
left with the old dog and we don't know
what they're gonna be without those
weapons we
see well can counter live up to the
expectations they still have to fix that
defense yes and now lions getting older
oh hold on I'm getting older the defense
isn't as as scary and ferocious anymore
I don't think these young guys in this
division
don't know what they don't know yeah and
Mike Tomlin has to be on the hot seat
oh he's a thousand percent on the hot
seat I have a ton of questions from the
fans that we're gonna get to I have some
news and notes that are coming out and
this one's from Joe underscore Choi what
would Bart have done if a teammate or X
teammate did what a B is doing with juju
and then now we've seen Ramon Foster and
Pouncy come out and say before you put
this on social just text it to me and
I'll handle it what would you have done
if this was your team and a teammate
left and was still doing this to people
on your team well to me you got to
support the young dude right because
he's a young guy he was a fan of Antonio
Brown and Antonio Brown thought that he
was going to embarrassed a kid because
he reached out to him and he looked up
to him crazy he just showed him to love
or respect that you would expect the
game coming in into the league to show
somebody that's been doing it at a high
level for a long time I think it
endeared everybody to Jude it's actually
I don't understand what's a B's point so
at some point you have to move move on
you got your money you got your wishes
that you did they try to send you to
Buffalo you block that you went exactly
where you wanted to go may not be the
place that you want to go but it's one
of your places on your list and he's
like at this point at some point you got
to move forward and you got to
understand it now pressures on you
because the pressures on you just as
much as it is on us Tillis to make sure
that you have a better season because
you got to say it wasn't about Ben
Roethlisberger he didn't make me this
offense didn't make me this team didn't
make me I am a I'm not a system god I'm
a guy that can flourish and be a top
receiver at any level with any
organization so he needs to go to work
and shut his mouth it's not like they're
in the same division and a rival just
isn't Landon Collins going to the
Redskins saying hey you guys moved all
for me you guys should chose me so now
I'm a man he forced his way right so
what do you think NFL players are
thinking about with a B right now
they're like do I feel like the juju
thing was the final straw I felt like
the Big Bend comments everyone secretly
doesn't like
big Mennonite I feel like also when he
got the contract every NFL player was
like you actually fought for us the juju
thing was you've all been college kids
coming to the league you've all had a
guy that you looked up to and that
relationship is super strong and when
you kind of like disrespect that that
felt like it offended everyone in the
NFL because the kid came in with his
humble pie right he came in he said all
the right things he did all the right
things he looked up to you it's like
it's like like that song with Rick Ross
when idols become like idols become
rivals right talked about cash money and
about how he realized all their cars
were rented and I love that [ __ ]
absolutely you know so that's kind of
what it reminds me of and then every
that's actually very because what if the
Raiders draft DK Metcalf if I'm [ __ ]
DK Metcalf I'll not ask any Antonio I'm
not sending him [ __ ] because you know he
gonna do melee but the thing is is what
did he out that juju wanted to get
better and that juju looked up to you at
college I mean he should look up to
anybody that's in approach because
that's really inspiring for tips and
things that sorted in he said all the
right things when you got traded
understanding that now is more pressure
on him because now he's gonna be their
number one receiver he's gonna have to
live up to those expectations one of the
safeties Justin Reed goes you know
that's disrespectful
i'ma knock him out or like I'm gonna
when if I play him do you think
defensive players in the NFL are like
you know what i'ma shut up a B well I
think people looked at a be like that
was too homey
like he's very likable was dances funny
stuff like that I didn't think people
took offense to some history Anakin's
you know to me he reminds me more like
Chad Johnson right try a Johnson was a
guy that you like man knock Chad out but
he funny here the guy you wanted a pup
because you can tell he's like hard and
it's fun yeah where tio was more vulgar
in your face it's like oh I did this to
you you wanted to hurt him you wanted to
come out there him and where do you
think a beef I think I think he just he
just made that transition from being
Chad Johnson to being
terrell tio to being TO WEAR guys like
you know what I'm a smack smack knock
that smile off his face I'm gonna make
him pay and you know this guy's not a
good guy he's a douchebag you know I
mean nobody wants to mess with him yeah
I think guys are gonna start looking him
up and trying to try to come out them
he's not
get the benefit of the doubt he also
doesn't have the quarterback to throw
him in the perfect spot anymore yeah cuz
big bad man through an unbelievable deep
ball I can you imagine having been in
the AFC North what vantes Burfict did to
a beat and now they're on the same team
yeah I get it similarly I could because
you kind of respect that that he plays
the game right wait
like Burr flick would have been a
perfect stiller hmm right because he
fits he fits the Jason Gilda's of the
world he fits the joy porter's of the
world Jory port come on man his do it
was great scraping dudes up in Vegas we
were talking about when he beat up Levi
Jones he beat him up at the at the craps
table some follow Micah yeah yeah so he
did that what else it PZ do anybody have
real green so was there ever time were
you perfect and Porter were all in the
AFC North at the same time no he was a
little bit younger than us PZ was gone
but um Hines Ward was the same person to
us you know he was the chief showers he
was a fantastic you know on the other
side Craig blocks and all that stuff you
take an air redoubts nice guys diving at
people legs we had that rivalry where I
remember one time when Tomlin was like
yo they were going to playoffs and
everybody knew I was gonna get him cuz
everybody's trying to get him cuz he
would come see the thing about being a
receiver you can come in two different
worlds and you can bounce back to yours
and nobody can come out to your space
cuz you can split out wide and you can't
even touch him yeah but but then he
comes in you know why you handling
business you know the front side that's
what he used to do I mean he he asked me
decapitating type of hits so you know I
remember they were going to playoffs and
Tomlin didn't play him one game because
he was like I'm not gonna give him to
you really cuz that cuz it got to the
point where Hines war where we were
going to guys were saying you know what
forget to play forget what's going on if
he's around you I'm fine if he's on the
inside of a bunch and if I'm finally
Jared Johnson probably gotta like the
like what he think he was on his knees
crawling wow I got him like finally got
him you know buzzin it funny though that
when a wide receiver cracks on a
defender fans are like redemption as
though they get hit yeah
did that upset defenders because I feel
like Hinds was known as the smiling
quarter
back receiver but in the league it
sounds like defenders are like you'll
[ __ ] that guy yeah cuz he was cheap shot
arse that's cheap shot artist you know I
mean because you can come into our world
you hit us when we're not looking at you
trying to be tough but you know Heinz
was a tough player he was a scrappy do
and if he if the Ravens would ever
brought him over he would've been
embraced realized so it's one of those
guys that you hate to play against but
you understand the respect his grinding
his hustle what would a kind of player
come in that you wouldn't embrace Richie
incognito Coley type of stuff it's not
even a bully something the things that
he used to do was career-ending type of
things like diving it's kneecaps trying
to hit you from the back those are
things that stop my ability to be able
to feed my family so there now we got I
try least Hines goes high is what you're
saying yeah I mean it's cheap shot
artist stuff but like you could you can
kind of him like where Richie was coming
it was like standing over the pile
trying to cut you about over the pile
push you over the pile of that type of
stuff yeah I mean that's why he was at
one point he was like the most heavily
fine person in NFL history I think he he
probably finished his career over like
three hundred thousand dollars in fines
yeah me I tried to fight him one time
yeah man it it's just interesting that
the Steelers finally don't make the
playoffs and it implodes yeah have you
been on teams where like winning masks
that [ __ ] and then as soon as you start
losing all the fingers start getting
pointed and the real characters come out
are you talking about the Santonio
Holmes eight Nate trying to play for the
playoffs in Miami trying to fight the
offensive line as we're trying to go for
the game-winning alright so tell me the
story I didn't ask that knowing I asked
that yeah what probably has a story of
well you know we have went to back to
back and see championships we got off to
a fast start our third year but then we
lost some games in a row
all we needed to pretty much do is win
one game to get in and that's when San
Antonio I think that was a year - but
fumble but if it's the last game of the
season we win pretty much we go 9 and 7
and we're pretty much in playing Miami
Miami's not that good but it's selfish
South Beach is undefeated we're in a
battle we're going down Santonio is our
our best receiver and all of a sudden
like you see ruckus inside of the the
huddle and they're pushing in there
arguing there screams and fight he like
what the hell is going on yeah
San Antonio is trying to fight the
offensive line in the offens line don't
want no part of them I think they talk
about the huddle right cuz what are you
gonna do with an offensive line yeah
yeah take the own take that it's kind of
like money Mike have you ever seen a
rock wall - Wi-Fi - rock wall oh yeah me
but it ain't pretty it's okay so I mean
they thought mild and then I was kind of
like the beginning his demise as well
you know and so I witnessed it I
witnessed that infighting and it's hard
to really win when you have guys hehehe
I called them out
Santonio was a was a good player and I
just think he didn't know how to
articulate what he was trying to say you
know because he had said some thing
they're asking like well because the
pressure was on him because year before
he won a bunch of games since first year
coming over he had just got his contract
and you know people were saying well you
know what's going on what's going on
with your production he was saying well
you know for the offensive line has to
block better and then we can make take
more shots under fill' that's not what
he was saying right like he was trying
he just couldn't articulate and he they
put his locker right next to mines and I
used to be sitting there like that ain't
gonna come off right really so I've been
there
oddly enough it's funny because the same
thing that juju was kind of was doing to
a be like pushing him to be like - I
think he got just as many targets as
being a B's kind of upset probably about
that a B did the same thing - right
because that's how he got there right so
like you know the same thing make you
laugh make you cry and it's how you
handle those situations I tell people
all the time in football we all die our
football death but you know you get an
opportunity to decide how you die you
can die like a coward you know by like
sabotage and young guys and not being a
good teammate holding on for as long as
you can right holding on and trying to
force your hand and force your power
your authority with the organization to
suppress a talent that's ready to merge
but really like or you can be a guy that
helps everybody and say you know what
this young kid is he's ready to take the
mound I mean when when Shaq was with the
way he realized that Dwayne was a better
player he was a great player but he was
on a decline he relented he said
what young fella this is your team now
and I felt like a bee wasn't ready to do
that and he still was playing at a high
level and sure but it was coming maybe
not this year maybe not next year but
definitely in three years I think it'd
be put that part where you know juju was
gonna pass I think I'm gonna make a bold
prediction right now I think a bees like
gonna fall off in about a year and a
half I was two years I would say to you
I think like what he's gonna have a good
season and I think halfway through next
the season after that and the main
reason is I just compare them to other
players like you know I looked at Chad
Johnson yeah and it was they played the
same amount they've had very similar
success Chad went to the next team and
then with change all the comfort zone
goes away new quarterback no ouch the
nuances go away and I'm sure that's what
happened to San Antonio to where you you
come from an organization where you're
winning and everything is clicking and
then you go somewhere else and you're
like I never had to worry about this
[ __ ] for the last eight [ __ ] year
because the system gets to grow and part
of our success and my success was always
being with Rick's I only had to be under
one system now that system was able to
grow same thing you see with Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady we were somebody
for so long what happens is you've seen
everything so you've been in every
situation so you can dig deep
I think that's sometimes why why Eli
struggles too it's because it's not like
four different offense right right so he
doesn't know the new one Newton - Cam
Newton sound like a new OC every year
right because sometimes it comes a point
in a game where you it's no answer and
you have to be able to take the tools
that the coaches giving you and figure
it out because you're gonna see
something that you've never seen in a
situation that you've never been in this
for you got to be able to think it out
so when I was always reacts whether I
was in Baltimore I was over here we can
recall on some mr. nonverbal
communication between people that played
with each other for so long right I
remember being with it playing every we
had been together at this point like
seven years and you know he was like hey
Bart you know I remember in a playoff
game we played the Wildcat right he
jumped he jumped the slant and took a
slant and that kind of sealed the deal
yeah he was supposed to be the post
player I was a three receiver slant guy
but he saw something and
he knew that I knew the defense or
nothing I knew his job and he I know
that he knew my job yeah so he just
switched it on the fly and was it like a
signal did he tap you did he say
something he was like he liked me get
the post like bet alright so I'm in the
box I take the post he jumped a slant he
takes two hot
I mean Pennington don't know what the
hell he's looking at cuz he never seen
him before right so that's what that was
the beauty we should call it organized
chaos feel like we don't know what we
don't you don't know we doing and that's
the beauty oh wow I had so many
questions from the listeners about Rex
yeah like your relationship with Rex is
fascinating no doubt first time you met
him like could you tell that you guys
were gonna work well together
it's which is weird because the first
time I actually met Rick's I really it
went it went a while before me before I
can even really notice him so he was all
he was on the Ravens staff when you got
drafted yes I mean he was the offensive
he was the defensive line coach oh wow
so Mike Nolan was the Marvin had left so
Mike Nolan was the defensive coordinator
Mike Smith was my linebacker coach right
Danny Henderson was the defensive backs
coach and Benny Thompson was which
pretty and Gary's honor was the special
teams coach Rex was alignment you know
he's big dude we just always mess around
he was what what I reckon I was like my
second year when I really started paying
attention to Rex because his job was to
blitz packages so like Mike NOLA come up
to scheme but then you know we have like
the presentation day and all that stuff
and he was and Mike Patton was uh he
failed practice that's what his job was
yeah we see the Packers hey yo yo yo
Mike tight Frank dumbass make sure the
frames so we can see it he was just a
low assistant hey why shy he up there
with the bungee cord yeah yeah we should
like kick up and ask those snowballs in
employment like like it was funny like
these days would take wrecks and like
he's like a local teddy bear man yeah
they take snow like the old man's snow
hit him yellow balls is just patting her
x-bow oh really so you guys are just
hitting your coaches I kind of reached
man it was crazy there we said like we
should do stuff like uh and other teams
don't do this I don't know we used to do
like bowling like like we would bow like
like we'll do take like petting or take
take our assistant put them in like the
garbage bag
on Friday set him up I mean the cloner
been set him up like bowling pins push
them all the way down the hallway just
let him go they fall out and it's Mike
Patton like allowing you to do this or
you like just shut up and get in the bin
he have a choice like damn you damn bird
go get the donuts so who was the one
it's funny because when he came here
with two Jets like I had never seen this
guy before
right because it's like it was like
we've all been to college yes we've all
ran into somebody that we knew from the
neighborhood and we like and we see
people show him respect you like this
cue ball this piece of [ __ ] I will give
you atomic wedgie and kick you an ass
right what did Patton do when he saw you
in New York
nobody saw me in New York cuz he was
like don't put me in the thing no no no
no he's had he's had like the the
peninsula you know me so he had like you
have the pasty bald spot oh yeah it was
like it was like Samuel Jackson on shaft
I came here was all Shea's had to go to
but he'll you get a goatee whoa steady
cool like on player scared of gizelle
Noah you know he came for the rape is
he's defense coordinator so are you in
the locker room be like nah [ __ ] this
guy I ain't blow up his body because at
the end a day he still was part of the
family yeah cuz I knew him before but
like we'd be sitting here like you know
me Jim littered like you know Trevor
price yeah Marquis Douglas if you look
like this boy I think he tough it was
gonna smack the [ __ ] that's so funny so
like I just actually spend time up there
but it was funny because as Rex
continued to improve and get promoted I
kind of got promoted as well you know
Mike Smith ended up leaving then hi
Singletary man funny thing was watching
AF watch secretary say hey
Singletary can only be a head coach not
a exa no guy no yeah he's just there for
the speeches
yeah that's what have you been doing to
reach some some some anger some some
Surry County tsunami hurt me that's all
I saw Singletary was that was his job
basically well think about it with San
Francisco my ad story right he got the
head coaching job because he said I want
winners yeah yeah and the rest of the
dumb public is like that's what a head
coach looks like yeah yeah I told you
the ad story did I no you did not oh so
Mike came late right Mike came to the to
the building late so we were already
there he came like the second or third
year so
was crazy first first time every mean
Mike was uh we you know doing our drills
and stuff like this he's from the old
school straight Junction boy type so he
played on a buddy right so like you know
Peter Boulware first of all never came
to training camps he always get a
surgery or some so he'll have to show
what Ray really did show up or nothing
like that so like you know he decides to
give us these rubber bands he has this
chute so we understood and we you know
we shuffling whatever he shuffled with
us Pete like he's killing us like this
is like this is like now today like I've
seen so much there rayon and Peter like
man y'all need to go talk to you boy
he trip it really talking eyes he's like
yo he tripping man that's like funny he
killing us like we tweet Daniel Terry
doesn't know any other way he'll know
nothing right so so so so we don't it
again and Peter Bourjos he's had enough
he like God he falls Peter don't cuz he
really religious guy oh really
yeah from I ran for Congress all this
stuff so he he follow like God dangit so
he takes it throws the rubber band down
right witness shoot me while redhead art
well still in in there going die he like
waiting on you beat stop like but what
can you say to singletery because he's a
great player like you're a great player
favor right so like at this point like
they go to Ozzy so we get off to a bad
start right right so we sit so he's
sitting in there and we we had been in a
defense longer than him so we know the
defense more than he knows it so he's
coming in and he was say stuff that was
wrong but out of respect for him we
wouldn't say nothing Wow except ad
background story for our listeners right
ad is the same person that got into it
with Bill Belichick when he became a
patriot because him and Randy Moss
showed up late for practice one day
because of the snowstorm and he said he
don't know what and they got sent home
and he said I don't know what Bill
wanted me to do ain't a dainty frickin
Jetson my car don't levitate I can't fly
over the traffic it was traffic I call
we got a job and his tender with the
patrons weren't that wasn't that what
say these full name again a daddy's time
oh yes okay yeah so so so we sit so we
sit so he's sitting in the meeting right
he's that guy so sitting there wait so
he was the guy
more than you were the guy no ad was a
classic [ __ ] like straight like like
you realize that the Matt backer saying
that somebody else is off the rails yeah
is it is an insane thing to think about
we got a same birthday really it's funny
you said that's hilarious
I saw him the other day too but anyway
so we sit and we sit in meeting right so
he's that guy he's that guy that's never
gonna let nothing get by I'm like the
funny guy he's like the guy like gotcha
so just a difference between the funny
guy in the [ __ ] yeah huge so so so so
we sit in there and Singletary's up
there trying to draw something you like
he was like we like he's like coach we
like coach man that's wrong he was like
you know what be right back
so he leaves goes out I guess he goes
axe Rex I asked Nolan he was wrong right
so it comes in there things like you
know you guys right so he goes do it
again ad was like Michael just wrong -
he say so Singletary turns around always
got the wood cross only safe every time
I say something it's always the same
person a D D right like 20 times like a
substitute teacher that snaps he wrote
ad over itself like maybe 50 times and
just yelling are we all looking like god
this dude is having a [ __ ] breakdown
do you understand what I'm saying to you
son do you a really good Singletary
prison what would you say
dude just fast eyes basically having a
breakdown I probably go my bad coach you
understand what I'm saying you son now
road you Albany do fear Oh your dad you
just freaked out he's torta dad are you
guys just dying
yeah we're cracking a buck a day still
Tony who do you want me to walk the road
yeah so what we realized is singletary
don't know [ __ ] about the Exynos he
played in the 46 yeah and his job he had
to run him back every time damn and
that's what his job was so you accent
over to he don't know what everybody do
so 46 is a cover one system so that
means somebody got to tidy a man man so
it's not complex no so we laugh it's in
that shop type of tea because we knew
more about the defense than he did but
he couldn't help so he needs to be hey I
said all that to say he could never be a
coordinator he needs to be a guy that he
needs to be the rat rah-rah guy they
were calling McCarthy a CEO yeah yeah
he's over yeah so that when you see with
the AAF here just left
he's Flavor Flav no no because who did
he have with him I don't know yeah
Dennis Thurmond DT was our coordinated a
whole time that's the thing about the
NFL is there are these coaches that are
so good at X's and O's but they get
pushed down by the personality guys yeah
that are better in the media because
being it been a head coach is about
being the face of the organization and
you can have guys that can draw up plays
and draw up schematics but they can't
motivate men like a Mike Martz type of
situation yeah yeah but but then you're
socially awkward and you can't relate to
people so you'd rather have a head coach
that's a great leader of men than a
great football mind yeah because if my
coordinator just needs been my football
mind cuz that's a guy that I'm just
spending most of my time with yeah cuz I
feel like people get frustrated by
Tomlin but I'm like I feel like Tomlin's
a good motivator of men yeah I think so
you know soul brother was that a pal
he's path yes that's fine I do
undercover brother I do feel like NFL
players do like Tomlin though we do yeah
you know what I like about Tommy no
matter if it's if his team loses he
never makes excuses ever it's just like
quitting it we didn't get it done we got
to be better you know that the reality
of it is that the calls aren't going
with walking with Kelsey and mahomes and
they were telling me that Andy reads the
coolest [ __ ] coach they've ever
had yeah that if anything goes
he puts it on him he gets there and he
he's just cool yeah and I think that's
you need a guy like I could have rocked
with Bruce Aaron - Oh Bruce Aaron gets
down any dude I got a got a Kangol [ __ ]
paint chips twice not once he paid twice
like the flavor
hey yeah bro what is wrong with you
you're crazy all right we need to get
back though to Rex Ryan he's a d-line
coach he's in charge of blitzes and I've
heard Giants in the 90s talk about I
remember Phil would tell us that they
would see Belichick and they'd go he
would have some crazy to [ __ ] my place
was it similar with Rex Ryan he was like
a beautiful mind like man this dude is a
talent that we he needs to be set free
but in my mind I go you bring a
linebacker you bring a safety what's so
beautiful about that but what was there
a play that you remember or it's
everything it's like he always has
something new and innovative that's why
you never knew it was coming just think
Rex is the first person that stood
everybody up like everybody else doing
this all a NEMA type of type of defense
where nobody said everybody's moving
around off his line don't know who to
identify that was they stole that from
Rex and I kind of stole from his dad
because the original 40 60s he made was
like we're bringing anybody that you
don't see but see but that's the
difference is in the 46 everybody was
sick so yeah it was it was a crazy
defense it was basic cover one to cover
zero meaning man and man no help inside
out you know you got some certain places
now Rex had to put the 46 in because he
said be written out the will was
hilarious but no true story buddy
would've kicked ass up but I love buddy
but he stood up everybody standing up
hello T lining up at safety let me ask
you this take me to the practice or the
meeting room the first time everybody's
standing up was pitched to you guys do
you remember that not the exact time but
I remember what what it was but it was
as Rex was a great teacher to say
understanding that really when you hear
what does the DS line cause me 5-volt
you know what that means our five got
their big five well if they can't
identify who our big five is right then
it doesn't matter is that how we pitched
it to you guys yeah he was I listen like
because we
all knew what each other was supposed to
do because everybody there was
intelligent it sounds like I mean
everybody there was like could be played
multiple positions so like sometimes I
would play safety remember he said he's
the same defense coordinator that line
dat de leus up at squat corner at 270
pounds
he's like your only job ad is to throw
Chad Johnson into the Gatorade and then
sitting squat in the corner
you're the squat corner and so like a
cover to just like yes I'm doing the
flat right so you're the squat corner
anybody come to the flat I want you to
put your heart shut crap Seth told him
in the Gatorade and tags like we see ad
colonies a collar damn he wasn't quick
enough to get away from him Adela's
remember remember who does Thomas was he
was he was at one point was some the
most deadly weapon in football for two
years he led the league in in in sacks
Wow just all blitzing that's why billet
billet egg wanted to snap to that's why
that's why he stole him from the Pro
Bowl thousand six with the Pro Bowl day
they having secret meetings really yeah
he signed him there he was just picking
him up me like I'd a yes I can use you
know hey he does come talk and they
would go away really dad and talk and
were you like were you guys do you we
are no he's gonna be out cuz we knew he
was a free agent but remember he you
want your friend to secure the bag and
yeah remember remember he also went to
the Pro Bowl as a gunner on a punt team
torn this is to be the funniest thing
ever man many days has begun errs wow so
so usually see the double-team walking
out there trying to they're like okay
he's to seven corner a wide receiver yes
he just smacked him in the face
Bop and stiff arm and then he's still
fast enough to run away from cuz he's a
forty five forty cheese so Rex created
that he put her low D a safety I
remember he set up a scheme because he
understood the blocking schemes of the
bangles so he put slow TS safety then he
will put me at at the off linebacker who
my job was to come across and go into a
gap to take the center with me right lie
somebody else in a be gap to open that
up take the guard
hello T's at 12 yards
running downhill guess who has to pick
him up running back the running back
freight train he spent him like a top
Wow I think he knocked him out with his
knee cuz he tried to cuddle
he tried to cuddle Odie hello he's 240
it was two hits don't go dead if the
knee it was night-night Wow
it was Rudy some Rudy that they said was
it at a point where Rex would get up in
the meeting and diagnose a blitz and you
guys would be like they're gonna have no
idea what's about to have oh how you
think I killed Ben it was off a blitz
that was designed to confuse because we
knew what they Center did if who was
diagnosing that Rex Rex would watch the
film and see it we know that I stunts he
knows like em so they they had a sinner
they used to put his hand between it he
put his head but his his holes get up he
puts his head between his and his arm
legs looks at Ben looks up does this and
puts his head back down then it snaps up
Oh see you could tie in that out to a
tee you got it so I lined up on this
side so the left side of the offensive
right the right side and offensive line
yeah their left side but our right yes
he puts his head down i sprint all the
way to the other side
Adelie is it standing over Neath the
tackle so by the time he you're on a
completely different side so he slid the
line the wrong way when he put his hand
behind we all went couple of us went the
other way so then when been hiked and
they can't they end up one man short so
a Delia's job is to touch the lineman so
if I touch you and your attack when I'm
a I'm a D in what are you gonna do I'm
gonna react to you my point dinner date
he's dropped that cuz his responsibility
was to curl flat so now he has no back
flat sawed open and the offensive
lineman is completely facing ya if you
ever pull that play up it's the funniest
thing ever man is he and is it would you
say this is the hardest hit on the
quarterback you've ever done yeah I
thought I thought he was dead
I thought he was dead and Ben still
credited as the hardest hit ever but it
would just mean I'd blown the layup
alright so Ben Roethlisberger and pretty
much would it so watch where I'm at
you'll see me okay don't worry see I'm
right here now watch his head down watch
me
bye-bye watch him bud watch a daze okay
back jakka
night-night look at Willie Parker I
thought
Hill who was coming I thought what had
happened was and night-night and that's
all Rex so how what does that feel like
to be on a team with a coach where like
every week you guys feel like you have
an advantage before the game ball even
gets snapped it's an empowering feeling
you know I mean like we were going to
you know that you're gonna be what the
Rams offensive players felt like last
yeah with Sean McVeigh yeah it and then
if you play for Bella cheque like every
[ __ ] game yeah but it felt empowering
yeah it's like it's like man they don't
know what's coming because every week
was something different cuz it was game
specific so he's a genius he's a
beautiful mind when it kind like
offensive coordinators couldn't study
what they did to the Steelers because
Rex isn't doing the same thing every
because he's designing his defense to
what you do hmm
so you can never you can and then what
happened is we have been together so
long that he can always create it like
oh they they doing something different
like we played the Patriots like oh they
doing something different remember that
the year did they one they went
undefeated we shut them down on Monday
Night Football us and that's when you
had all the penalties into the game you
were talking and I said yeah so Rex Rex
is a guy like that so I hope he gets his
opportunity to get back in the league
but it's probably gonna have to be like
as a college coach first I always dig
Vermeil type that I wish Rex would just
be a DC yeah because that's clearly
where as special to you and I kind of
thought as it went on
he just started playing the head coach
rolled too much and it I don't know like
I don't want to talk bad about your
former cono and I felt like it
it started tail off know the problem
with Rex is he's too loyal uh and he
loves to hard
he will go he's the guy that will sounds
like a thing that you say in that
interview is a hit your weakness I'm too
long yeah he will go down with the ship
and so he would keep guys on staff his
best friend Jeff weeks or he would keep
certain people there and they they
weren't carrying their weight or he
would say you'd off his coordinator I
trust you that's what his dad did right
that's what that's what I've got a
random cutting him yup but he was like
you figure that out I'm only focusing on
the defense right that's what buddy did
in Chicago too and he got the favorite
right so he trusts too many people mmm
and I felt like he made the mistake the
first time but then he went up to
Buffalo it was too soon he should have
been away from the game a little bit
then came back and learned from his
mistakes but he doubled down right can't
double down you got it father brought an
ad dad bring his brother him was the
worst thing because then his brothers
coming in he's like I'm his brother so
you can't talk down your brother your
brother you did here close but I'm your
brother the exact right so now have more
twins right so now it's not it's not the
it's not the different levels of command
chain right brother thinks he's you and
he's talking to you like and then it
just all implodes alright got another
question here this is about sort of what
like playing for your rival could you
Bart this is from Nick Rodriguez 22
would you have ever played with the Pats
after battling with the Jets for so many
seasons I having not rooted for either
of these teams did not realize that
Patriots fans [ __ ] hate you like it's
a past deep I didn't realize it was so
deep a lot it's like from the can't wait
stuff I think what did you say about the
Patriots that get they got them so
obsessed well I said something about the
Providence and how stupid they were
because they would like pull the fire
alarm I said that on my radio show yeah
they didn't take today oh you about like
being accused of anything they're jerks
many come on man they pulled it man you
ever play you do stay in Providence and
they gonna pull your fire alarm about
three o'clock in the morning Oh facts
all the time yeah all the time
or they gonna stand on the build across
from the hotel and yell with like
microphones all the time my bro like
really I kind of appreciate that it's a
really good strategy I hear you but if I
catch you in a kitchen that stairwell
you'll get to you a little night-night
if they really hate me I listen like I
the Patriots fans in this office I was
like yeah Bart's coming later and
they're like [ __ ] anything god I'm
not here alright how do you gonna do I
didn't even play long enough only play
for the just for four years why do you
hate me so much I think because they're
just so arrogant so used to winning that
they can't handle that for one game and
a big moment we took it from I think
it's because you said can't wait and
then beat them in the playoffs it's
never [ __ ] happen they don't lose in
[ __ ] Foxborough
I mean but they lost to the teams that I
play for they they they lost to the
Ravens in the same fashion they don't
hate the Ravens they respect the Ravens
but they hate the Jets just like
stepchildren you're probably up there
for like player with the most wins
against Belichick in like big games
percentage-wise is this one this one I
hate me right this how no they hate me I
mean oh yeah I made fun of Kraft so like
recently yeah recently yeah well
whatever I just keep your hands on the I
just said listen do the right thing the
wrong way you should have showed up
listen I want like yes you were saying
this yeah yeah show up eight o'clock I
want the first appointment why you want
to if if Belichick called you up you
could have gone to the Patriots would
you have wanted to try out for the
Patriots and see what it was like I mean
David Harris went to the Patriots Reba's
went to the page they just steal people
off our team all the time all the time
mark we Scholl Sean Ellis Josh I know
this has do you think players the NFL
want Bella cheque to call them up and it
validates them in a little bit that if
you get that call by the Patriots that
you're kind of like [ __ ] Belichick
season to me see I think belcheck I
think Belichick didn't realize that I
was probably the type of player that he
needed see he got me late in my career
but I had all attributes that you would
want for from a poor what I think he
looks for in a page he's a guy I was
always a guy that was willing to be a
team first guy I was able to do multiple
things I used to do multiple things I
played a former defensive end for the
Ravens yeah safety linebacker and I was
I was a cannon ball for for a sounds
like you wanted the call no no no no
because in speaking a day is not enough
quality life is horrible
really people that play up their players
they play up their hate it you have to
sacrifice they hate is like a miserable
being but you win Super Bowl so you feel
good but the people that went up there
that didn't win regret it so when like
the lame Johnson quotes come out about
it's not fun and and I'd rather have fun
and win then like not have fun yes it's
for real for real yeah yeah listen it's
more some people need that focus though
yeah I mean that's why I mean I want to
see like what this team is like without
Tom Brady but I think Bill and leave
so we'll never know I think bill wants
to stick it out for a few more years
after that to prove that he can do it
without Tom he can't rather he realize
it or not he can't I don't know he did
his 11:05 matt cassel three-in-one
without brady they got a winning record
without get it but that's because you
get you get spotted six for planning and
division that you play in so you only
beat a couple of teams that were
actually good right the rest of team you
just feasted on your don't know I think
Bella checks the greatest coach that's
ever lived and and I maybe he's done
more for brady than Brady's done for him
I don't think so I don't think so I mean
Adam that's not me trying to throw shade
at Bill Belichick no like a lot of
things that he gets up like letting guys
go too soon like this that's a very Bill
Walsh thing Bill Walsh was known for
that let you go with like two three
years left in your career like Mike
Malloy law Santee Sam use like he would
have won a couple more Super Bowls if
you'd have Richard Seymour in that
defensive line on some of those things
that he lost but he's won so many that
we don't really critique the ones that
he's lost and we don't talk about we'd
always talk about how great he is in the
draft but we don't talk about all the
misses his head
oh no I've come at Belichick I think
that Bella checks we everybody's
weaknesses the draft the dress just
[ __ ] impossible see what he does is
he catch people that's desperate people
that it's only on their last leg they
want to submit their legacy so they're
willing to like you know like Bennett
he's willing to try and win a
championship well right so so he'll so
he'll play at a high level in a specific
role and he'll take less just because he
wants to win yeah and then you win he
gets me get rid of your ass did he ever
talk to you on the sidelines no I told
you like I want to smack the [ __ ] out of
him like on NFL today it took everything
in my life on the set of NFL today on
CBS no on a sideline Oh [ __ ]
rule like listen first of all I'd do if
I to do a financial literacy program
with Morgan Stanley
financial Lucy I go to every team I've
been a Seattle Seahawks three times
Tampa man I need to talk to you like
Tampa Houston's I ain't saving [ __ ] you
see all these sweaters I got a rock out
Chicago man no I don't want to do that
enjoy life man listen game still young
man I gotta say [ __ ] young enough to
enjoy but anyway so you're going around
the team's to in financial literacy and
the pages will let me come
I'm like so I got information to help
your team and you won't even let they
light heat bill and never let you in the
building
like we don't think that's a you thing
I'm like we still got B from Medellin is
that because the stories that I have
heard when Simms was here talking about
their privacy and how they're the only
team what does he think I'm gonna do
like we take a reconnaissance footage
it's I don't play for them no more
either dude I think that Belichick
believes that you would have come in
with buttons that were recording stuff
he apparently take his big board it's
locked under a metal garage door again
that no one's allowed in the [ __ ]
room bro and that they have you walk in
and you sign in and then there's another
door like it's run like a CIA that just
let you know how much information he
steals
absolutely absolutely you only prepare
for other people's [ __ ] if you have
thought of that [ __ ] right exactly like
Belichick probably like I'd love to see
the 49ers facility and it's like [ __ ]
Groot
from you know he's got all the guardians
of the galaxy you know just like oh now
that damn Despicable Me oh yeah yeah
like he's got all this like secret
recording chocolate chip cookies that
are rolling around like that's [ __ ]
Belichick yeah yeah he didn't let you
let me in
no for real but you know we're on the
sidelines too AM C championship me
coward and gun and Tony's sitting there
chopping it up because you know this are
you know this man Tony's first AFC
Championship we we not in the studio we
all set it's cool as loudest AFC
championship he walks up speaks to
shakes Tony's hands speaks to Tony
speaks to Bill I'm literally standing
we almost shoulder-to-shoulder and
you're like all right here my turn
no he says absolutely nothing to me
don't even look at me and at that point
I'm like look bro now you've been an
[ __ ] it's fine you've been an [ __ ]
over there but you came over to us so
this is outside the lines yeah group up
and Tony kind of gate it looked like a
bus a [ __ ] blood pushes my life
[ __ ] like [ __ ] because that's just like
some [ __ ] yes let me let me see some
other questions here oh this is amazing
rhinoceros spelled interesting what was
it like growing up with two of the
whitest first names Bart has got was
hilarious more solid I always get the
man with two first names oh yeah who's
this barks got a Scott your first name
or a last name yeah it was weird man cuz
I grew up in the hood man so it was like
Black Bart and all that type of stuff
like who named you Bart who named you
Bart like my dad name's Bart yeah I
don't know what are you a big Simpsons
fan I was it's funny because we had Hank
Azaria on the show the other day and you
know he does all the characters yeah I
told him it's like The Truman Show thank
you you raised me yeah but it was it was
to come on the typical sub Black Bart
Bart Bart Bart Simpson get people
collect oh but then I was always the
most popular guy or what's the most
popular guy so it's like do you really
want you really want to go there you
won't just smoke man I thought that
parents and girls trying to fight me
because I was just oh no what do you
mean I would joke them every day you you
say one thing to me it doesn't stop
until you cry for the rest of our
existence you're coming for the neck
it's a train that come from where did
that energy come from because that is
you to a tee you are I will be friendly
to any [ __ ] that is friendly to
me
yeah I'm American as you [ __ ] cross
me I will [ __ ] bury ya where does
that come from when was the first time
that you felt that man first of all I
grew up in a house with all women women
you know my sisters are six feet in 510
so they beat the living [ __ ] out of me
locked me in the basement so you had to
get tough I grow sister say that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me all the time I mean what
I'm gonna do to him
my sister six feet yeah I'm she's ten
years old I mean other ones six years
older me so she's 16 I'm six I can't I
can't win that battle yeah yeah I'm
saying but you know I just always it was
always a snapback because in a hoodie
that you either either you like you the
prey or you or you or your predator your
domain so it's like one of those things
like those who just let people keep
getting on you you never you'll never
stay you're never shake it you just you
you're always gonna be fighting and
you're always gonna be you're always
gonna be on the counter all the time so
you come at me I come right at you
I mean sports I mean sports man you talk
about some of the most pressure-packed
joins you talk about high school sports
in Detroit rival schools you told me you
couldn't even go to the mall y'all might
getting a scrap if you see your rival at
the mall Wow you know I'm saying so it
was like that so you coming me I come
right back I remember you know I trained
at this place called test names this guy
there you know he's quiet but then like
hey I play for the Raiders so like he
was talking stuff like think he was fast
me install a that was like look bro I
was like man ha sorry you got to be to
get cut by the Raiders oh that hit him
was hard
oh that he probably was crying try to
fight me I'll say no and everybody want
to fight no no no no everybody let him
go like don'tdon't I don't do that hole
hold me back no no let him go
like cuz every once a while you got it
you got a show you gotta show people you
[ __ ] really need to cuz like if you're
coming for people like that then you
have to back it out and how did that go
it does he want that smoke no emo
decibel have you ever been in a fight
where you're like oh I don't know if
this was the right fight to pick yeah I
haven't been a real fighting a long time
and yeah I mean I'm always ready
apparently Oh someone said to me the
other day we were talking about like if
you had to go to jail how would you do
and I was like all I know is I'm gonna
put in my application to do the morning
announcements and hopefully I can be
funny enough to save my ass
I guess I'm [ __ ] like let's walk
around with a diaper yeah I'm scared
sorry I'm [ __ ] never yeah
what does it get ready with a pharaoh
and uh you know Kevin Hart oh yes here
should know I figure with him with Will
Ferrell and all that stuff a bad booty
man out there he real I know I don't
that scares the [ __ ] I don't commit
crimes not because I'm a good person
because it's so free like so I wonder
what too cocky six nines going through
right now
[ __ ] I bet you ain't got that rainbow
hair no more I come here you little skit
Oh Oh trouble
CPT motivation what was the craziest
conversation you had with Rex CPT no
this is just the person Oh
craziest conversation ah nothing crazy
nothing crazy just typical stuff I mean
it sounds like you guys had a good
relationship I do yeah I mean like I'd
used to go up there and talk with the
off days I should be up there with the
coaching staff sitting in there like oh
this what we doing this week all right
but you know when we came here was like
a partnership he decided to take a
chance on me I just wish we could have
got that championship it would have
validated everything oh man
and even if we would have got one
especially would have been early he'd
have been a king around here we almost
did it man it was just damn I don't
matter who did you lose to the Colts it
was distillers more than anything
because we had just we had we have
played the Green Bay Packers that year
and we only gave up nine but we lost but
we only gave up nine points they did
they did not want to see us they scored
nine points on us three field goals they
barely got past yeah yeah they barely
got past half court midfield Wow they
kicked three field goals because I think
I don't remember what happened in the
Steelers cave but they beat the
distillers distills lost I was with
Rodgers only on Superbowl oh but I mean
like what are the Steelers do to you oh
remember we we had you know we came out
because that was after the can't wait
game we're kind of lethargic van had
like 18 play drive at the beginning we
came out flat we came back tied it up
and then we were like one score away
we're on the one-yard line first and
goal from the one shining armor threw
the ball twice instead of you know on
the one-yard line
yeah Shawn green and lt said his running
a ball four times with wedge blocking
and just hell you could have quarterback
sneak I know they got Casey Hampton but
we had Nick mango we had we had well
Faneca was gone so we had Nick mango we
still had the best offensive line damon
woody act and but fumble guy you know
Brandon Moore
yeah so we could end in D'Brickashaw
Ferguson we could have just wears black
four straight times if we ground in
pound which is so funny because
Schottenheimer around around the ball
like a record amount of times yeah and
back then yeah back then that's how we
got there we were all ground upon he
wanted to be cute but that's what
happens when coordinators are trying to
get head coaching jobs and you know what
that flashy play you look at what
Shanahan did once Julio caught the ball
so well over wit yeah should run the
ball three times kicked a field goal got
you I always defend Kyle because I go
it's the only time in a sport where your
defense allows 35 straight points and we
blame the offensive coordinator for
running it twice because he got no he
got he got cute man he tried to pass but
I'm just saying like now the real
[ __ ] issues that Dan Quinton's
defense got [ __ ] merked in the second
half they had nobody yeah and because
you school when you score that fast in
office people forget same thing with
Chip Kelly fans it's hard the defense
because they're out there no other
office always gets more snaps this one
is from token take which is an amazing
token date what was the offensive player
that you feared the most going up
against I can tell you the player that
the Ravens were afraid of more than
anybody Fred Taylor running back they
were a Jacksonville Jaguars they were
man listen anytime when I first got to
the raven he reminds me have t.i for
some reason Fred Taylor just the way he
talks and Stoker yeah his hairline is
I've ever seen but it stopped like but
it was going early yeah but it's faster
eyes but it stopped they just stopped
it's like a dub you remember like Aaron
McKie high at one point it look like it
look like he had amazing reference yeah
w it's our tickets propecia yeah maybe
yeah absolutely
yeah we make you limp though really no
I'm about to start doing some work on my
hair and if it starts going let's go
start taking the other stuff to make
sure it's okay I don't know if he's got
know which one's stronger I better start
making some babies you engaged right
yeah but I still try to throw down
so what I'm saying is who cares about
your hair bro you may I'm trying to do
this [ __ ] for a long time boy other than
appropriate you better call Wes Welker
and relax and do that no I'm because
because [ __ ] because you win and then
you lose yeah so you getting propecia
you're gonna win you go get your hair
back what you gonna lose gonna go ahead
a limp noodle imma try though Oh
Fred Taylor yeah Fred Taylor man Fred
teller
like they were afraid like listen what
aspect of Fred Taylor they were they
were loved when they looked up and he
was hurt all the time they thank you God
here
just style of how they didn't want to
deal with Jimmy Smith and that was like
glue before I got there remember Jimmy
Smith has the record for the raid was
like 230 yards receiving in a game yeah
and Fred tell it was like fast strong he
was he was the first lady on bill Wow
remember he's line up and run nine
routes bro just straight go but he was
always hurt with Brunell and what what
we saw what we saw in New England was
was older Corey Dillon type French
seller but they were afraid of Fred
teller
oh oh oh Eddie George now remember
remembers the whole thing where they
said Ray took his whole oh he was trying
to be tough when he played against Ray
but they always just scrape him up Eddie
did get him one time yeah it was in the
playoff game I was there he kind of like
stiff re on the sideline good yeah but
Brad killed him so many times straight
to muscle many times I tell you who out
who I didn't want to mess with I don't
want no smoke I want a smoke with Larry
Allen oh my god I want to smoke where
was he in his career when you were
playing him he was still he's to play
like maybe three years
there are shame avoid slow down Adams to
close all hotel there are there are some
guys in the NFL history that no matter
what era they were in Jim Brown's one of
those guys yeah Larry Allen is one of
those guys Jonathan Ogden is one of
those guys we grow Willie Roaf only time
I ever seen these guys that you go
humans should not be like that only time
I ever seen ray Tapout like I want to
smoke Kansas City Chiefs
Monday Night Football I was in my second
year and they're like Bart you want to
go in I said nope don't want none of
that smoke it's just like the priest
Holmes treats us like green grease homes
Willie roll will shields waters yes oh
that hole when he went even Gonzalez did
you worry about it was done who was
basically a 3rd Tenace and Don who was
like 270 yeah he was unbelievable and he
was mobile yeah yeah and we playing and
that's the frame just went John Matt was
still calling damn that was like two had
to be like 2003 John Madden was still
calling games and Ray was on the
sidelines they picked him up on the mic
hey man what's up
three of them owe me somebody got to
make a plan uh man like Rallo you're a
great player I know I'm gonna serve all
right here there's just one man will
shells and waters was wearing his ass oh
wow and like priest was they had this
like power sweet but they were uh they
were put done at receiver right most of
him into Tony have Tony will Schiller go
ahead Willie Roaf and then they will
pull a Willie Roaf and shields around
and and done with block two people down
and they will pull around a lot better
and the safety had to take that oh holy
and Ray was like yeah like the the
band-aid and the blood was running out
both sides of his face cuz Willie Roaf
they bust him up good man they they hit
him in his face man broke man what is it
like when you have like a Larry Allen
like I apologize
hey listen I'm an [ __ ] I'll talk to
ya hey Mike oh yeah
[ __ ] oh I'm sorry I didn't know
that was you mr. Allen really I
apologize yeah I probably slow flows oh
so tall so I'm like I got his leverage
they should put yeah yeah I'm getting
low yeah so actually I knocked out Larry
sinners he tried to cut me and cut my
knee and I knocked him out the game's
funny [ __ ] but same game I'm coming off
the silo Haley I'm about to get his ass
but I get low it's tall my [ __ ] on
wall [ __ ] right so I come over and I
bend and instead of like trying to push
me he took his hand and smacked me on my
back and I look like splat right so all
of a sudden the entire Sun disappeared
and I'm like what the [ __ ] so I'm on my
stomach cuz he slapped me on my back and
I look up oh no and I see him he's
bought the he's bought the swan dive on
he's by the swan dive on me oh so I see
son I'm like yeah I swear I said no and
I started across arc and he caught me
right on my ankle ah that's the way they
get you guys it comes just falling on
you
he caught me on my ankle I was mad I was
crawling probably when he when he when
he started his initial light you can see
somebody
bending about to jump when he started
that he would have landed like on my
middle my back you could have broken a
rib I thought I broke my ankle but I was
i was a scrub and i was just i played in
packages so I was like forget this I
can't I can't tell nobody I'm hurt no I
mean you get like eight snaps again yes
I just taped it up man but man but Larry
Allen huh sorry mr. Allen so it's not
even like wide receivers in coverage
it's it's those guys they can't hurt me
that dough can hurt me man yeah - [ __ ]
500 pounds for reps he's doing a buddy
tonight nah that's why I say he is a
generational like we'll never see like
he can fit 20 years from now he would
have been fine and if you get him mad
that's the whole thing you don't want to
get a mad this dude's a thug from
Compton man I did not know he was from
Compton dad so much more to do I don't
know which one he is I don't know if he
a blood or [ __ ] but he was like about
that life life yeah damn do you know
that like how do you know that like how
do you find out where a players from
just people knowing like yo do like you
know like oh this dude's the core like
shine exactly like that's an aspect of
the NFL that I don't think people pay
attention to enough is like hometown
yeah like you being from Detroit
explained so much like if I saw that
somebody was from like Beverly Hills
like it completely changes what they're
gonna be like we all we all like like
just just look at the people that you
know this from Detroit could we kind of
all have let them out you got you got
jaylen right me and jaylen both talk
scrap always talk about the hook so much
Chris Webber kind of saying wake up
Jerome Benny's kind of same way Jerome
Bettis is one of the he's a lot like
Hines Ward where we think they're
friendly but then you realize they slung
back in the day and they don't give a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so you think you
think about bus gates Nick's in my ear
saying Carl banks yeah Carl banks you
talk you talked to uh you know magics
from that from that spot kind of all big
silly guys so the choice like the place
where like Detroit's like a place where
it's no guidelines right so big dudes
want to be little dudes right so if you
look at all the great stars from Detroit
promote most of them are too big for
their position right you know
you talk about well Chris Webber was
like more point forward Jalen Rose was
like it was like at all he was too tall
play point guard six five six six point
guard you look at magic same thing you
look at George Gervin same thing you
look at Steve Smith same Smitty Smitty
right so all these dudes like why do you
think that is I don't know because like
it's never it's never like guylines
because most of time in Detroit you
you're too big to play certain things
like gates was like a point guard like
six five fat due out their hand on a
rock
so like you can be affect like where
else can Jerome bin and say I'm playing
tailback any other city to put his as
that nose guard
that's awful there's always been big and
fat you know saying buddy but why is
that happening but in Detroit it's like
weird you you saw that in the water you
go to a park you see fat booth you see
fat dudes either like Escalade to hand
on the right you like make it a repose
oh no I got the rock Detroit - no no so
that's just how it is like the choice a
place where people like are bigger than
what they supposed to be and they play
positions that they really not supposed
to Braylon outwards from there
yeah I'm buoyant do but he always like
style is talking stuff who else is from
Eric well Larry Foote he was a jerk yeah
I mean but we the same way sir Biggums
right hey Anthony Adams right yeah me
Chris Jenkins damn talk about a big
[ __ ] I want to breakdance you
ever talked him like his type of gotta
intimidate he'll if you start laughing
now he laughs at his joke before he's
finished you better laugh - Mike smack
you on the back like he was a other than
Larry Allen he's the second biggest dude
I ever been around
really Haman or lemon Orlando bro Oh
Zeus yeah but I think Chris may be
bigger news ooh man when Chris was in
his private the Panthers that deal I the
first two years here
oh yeah if we don't want we don't want
to sweeter one side Scott head remember
we played without him he got hurt early
really early if we'd have played the
Patriots distillers anybody with him in
the playoffs healthy memory tours AC he
tore his ACL to D years in a row
yeah he was such a big signing to
bro I should just sit behind him and
laugh I'm like nope guess what I'm
standing right here
because I know this runningbacks about
to have to cut back cuz he bout to take
you Center and you're gar and [ __ ] I
welcome to the C gap I'm so I used to
watch him like he said tackler running
back with the defenders he would just
take him and push him back in and they
would run into him
III think it's the the aspect of
football it's the most disrespected
position are those interior diliman they
are the most impactful players in the
game nobody knows who the [ __ ] they are
they always get neglected in the top 100
list like I think Fletcher Cox is a
top-10 player in the NFL know here
because every single play oh no top 10
top 20 for sure yeah but I just mean
like those guys never get there
especially Haloti Ngata for your defense
was everything see so so that's the lead
Williams in the draft yeah oh you can
want the BOCES and and we're gonna have
an interview next week with Josh and all
that but like nah and I love them but
Quinn and Williams can change your team
for a decade and Oliver and Oliver now
at Oliver's not as big as him yeah but
he's gonna play dead but he's a free
technique yeah and when the Falcons had
Grady Jarrett they're a different
defense Aaron Donald like all those guys
when you have a coin he's not saying
when su was soo in to think you could do
anything against them this is a thing
and no disrespect to Casey Hampton but
all big men are created equally right
Casey was more of I'm not gonna push the
pocket but you're not gonna push me
right he was a gap holding right he
weren't going to get up to you as a
holder not a push yeah yeah you know Ted
Washington right so man Ted was the man
where's Chester McLaughlin was different
what about the two guys in Jacksonville
Marcus trout and yeah but see but he
couldn't carry I see but he could but he
couldn't move he was a holder right he
he was a big out in enduro yeah so the
the difference and those guys the most
dominant guys in that position I feel
him in my error to play was Hainsworth
Albert Haynesworth when he was trying up
when he was contract hello de nada
Chris Jenkins and I mean Wilfork is
still like those he was like one of
those plug guys - he still like one of
those fat guys kinda like Ted Washington
right Gary ball right like these were
big guys that were dancing bears like
Chris Jenkins could like breakdance and
spin on the top hello D was a rugby
player the best F there's like you know
they're so hard to find Quinn Williams
it's the next just like this the next
one yeah like we haven't seen guys
that's six five you know that can move
run and a strong can anchor but also can
split the gaps and get across right like
the Casey Hamptons the the Kelly Greg
those are different type of like I just
want to say this like I hear all these
mock drafts everyone's talk about they
need an edge Russia they need an edge
rusher how many more [ __ ] times do we
need to see that guards are not as good
as tackles and beat the [ __ ] out of them
they're horrible see what did the reason
why and just take advantage of that but
the reason for them hey we're we're just
how do you beat Tom Brady pressure off
the middle how do you beat Peyton
Manning pressure up the middle it's not
because of them yeah
it's every [ __ ] quarter but here
here's the problem with that when you
when you do have the nose guard he's
dominant yes even with su you can double
him all the time you can't it's hard but
now at leat but now it's 11 on 10 you
need both you need both yeah more you
gotta have it so you got to figure out
what you don't have that's why I think
the just need to get Timmy Jernigan and
then take Josh Allen get the inside with
the outside because they they thought
they were had gonna have that with was
litter or they litter whales haven't
shown it yeah yeah see if they would
have went bar they definitely go Quinn
and one yes see cuz bar is a Blitzer
though right he's like a de leus right
he's like he's exactly like that who's
really great athlete right he's a
Blitzer he's not a God as naturally but
could also play in the middle on Miller
he's gonna be by Miller that's gonna had
a handful that's what's interesting
about the Niners is you know the Niners
everyone say they're gonna go Bosa but
they just went and paid all that money
for D Ford and they got all those guys
inside they had a queen whim
look if they match up DeForest Buckner
and Quinn and Williams in the middle I
mean the only thing that sucks is
they've spent their last three first
settlements Solomon Solomon so I'm not
interested in a guy whatever well maybe
like he unlocks them because they need
they need they need a
outside Pyro's are here yes to see if
Leonard Williams is worth who do you
think that guy is have you watched these
guys yeah I like both was cool but in
two three four I think he's limiting him
in space and I also don't think Bose is
gonna get to you guys but maybe yeah I
think yeah I think that was the beauty
of it I think that Niners go Quinn wins
where they go greedy or they move back
yeah because they need any help on the
outsides and their defense is horrible
you know and they lost foster so they
don't have any linebackers and he's been
adjudicated he's been he's been he's
been he's been proven innocent at this
point and now you already let him walk
away
- Andrew golden underscore 17 what does
Bart think of the Jets new uniforms I
haven't heard your take alright um they
could be better but you are a fashion
guy so you are the right person to ask I
don't like I don't like the New York
Jets over here I think would be cool if
they would just put like a grey plane or
a cool playing nice little jet they're
like nice little logo right there yeah
New York Jets
I'm the worst at this I have never had a
good take about a jersey see this is a
problem with the Jets and teams that
only have two cuz there's no accent
color so that's why they have to make
the black read in the black yeah yeah
yeah because like can you bring it what
can we do in here to make Penn State
uniforms look nice nothing because not
accent color you think well the team's I
got the coolest uniforms Patriots cuz
they got red white and blue right then
they can throw the gray in there
sometimes yeah then you look at the
Giants same thing yeah you look at the
Seattle Seahawks because they can pull
it at neon color out you look at even
you look at me look at the Jaguars you
know they can pull the three colors yeah
so you're not a traditionalist you don't
like the Colts all white with the blue
you're not a fan wacky be yeah
like whatever you ever looked at the
coach uniformly oh that's tight some
people love the classics it's classic
but it's limited yeah thank you can you
what's the variation why don't white
blue and white what are gonna break some
blue pants yeah no I get it
and then because there's no black and
Aires they can't have a black dog you
know I just think that the public always
like these jerseys suck and I'm like I
don't really get okay in the middle you
know I mean like like is Bexley temper
because nothing you can do but
you see the put the little cool thing
there right put a strike when those
Denver jerseys came out though yeah they
were [ __ ] fire yes like the tooths
coming out yeah yeah they were awesome
see so they didn't want to make the same
thing so they put it on the shoulder no
I had a Terrell Davis Denver Jersey
groan yeah cuz I just thought they were
the coolest thing ever man I would say
like who got the best I mean the
Patriots throw backs are the best to me
the Oh with the stripes I think and this
is hard for me to say the Dallas Cowboy
Thanksgiving jerseys are the coolest
well if you go if you yeah the white
shoulders those stars on top they're
phenomenal see but like what can the
Lions do Randy silver they can't do
nothing I think also the powder blue
chargers are phenomenal with the white
helmet with the lightning bolt
I wish the Eagles could go back to the
kelly green and I know the owners like
working on the Reggie White Jerome days
because when I see those I see Randall
Cunningham almost getting sad gonna
throw I see Reggie White likely our boy
like that man
Oh miss a tackle yeah well let's [ __ ]
happen I had a Randall Cunningham back
in the day was just like a flat boy yet
and then on the back and had 12
Cunningham probably was a starter
absolutely let me be me hat I don't he
got in trouble when he was like let me
be me because they were trying to keep
him in a par oh man Randall was a
[ __ ] animal all right another one for
Andrew golden what do you think is Sam
Darnell I like Sam and I've been around
long enough to see when a kid got the
goods I think what he was able to show
you at the end I think it would became
too much because they started him right
teams figured him out he struggled in
the middle to see that he got a few
weeks off yet a game to go did there was
a smart go because of the injury hey
know what I don't know why teams can't
come out and say he's a [ __ ] rookie
yeah we're gonna give him four weeks
because we're about to play the Patriots
and the [ __ ] Jaguars and we're gonna
bring him back at the end of season
we're not winning the Super Bowl this
year yeah calm the [ __ ] down
I think I think I don't know why teams
can't say that I don't know either is
like I'm digging just come out with the
Rangers statement we are going to suck
we're rebuilding sorry like the Dolphins
right now we're like we're [ __ ]
tanking right
sorry yeah I know it [ __ ] up ticket
sales and all that but don't matter
nobody came to Miami where they went in
a nice Oh
that's what I wrote down before him
before we go back to Sam you said South
beaches undefeat undefeated I had a
conversation with Kenyon Martin that he
said if you see an NBA team in a
back-to-back Miami Orlando it's nice
they're not gonna be bad in Miami
they're gonna be bad in [ __ ] Orlando
and so I was like ooh betting mine
that's great yeah a South Beach is on
the feet I think the page is always lose
down there well I so do you know what
happens we my mom Johnny fan in my mind
I always thought you guys were in the
hotels at nine o'clock and you have an
NFL game and you're gonna be really
respectful tell me why I'm a [ __ ]
idiot well when you fly in first of all
you get you get maybe three four hours
free time but a tiny fry down you fly in
on a Friday or a Saturday on a Saturday
so you get there Saturday afternoon
maybe three o'clock three o'clock
you got one seven means at seven you
have four hours gotta gotta gotta gotta
be efficient see I would this is how I
would go I would get in the hotel and
I'd have plans and then I'd lay on the
bed and then I probably wouldn't do
anything probably not they fly in they
got a sidepiece or their main piece
waiting there for ya time ago I'll get
some action or if you wanted young guys
you might go to straight to a strip club
nothing like a strip club three o'clock
on a Saturday and it's the only time you
can get it just when you can get in and
get in especially if you come in the
wings are good Express strip clubs do
have the best wings that's what I hear
that's a fact I look at I don't know
what's in his sauce but that's a fat
look at Chad Johnson's Instagram last
night he's like I'm here for the food
it's a fact I'm telling you but but when
you go there I just don't like eating in
strip clubs why would you think the
cooks know I can't do it I just for me
it's like the biggest waste of money
ever the Jewish guy I mean this is I
can't do I lost it I lost a friendship
in Miami really I was like bro you can
never in your life come in my house and
drink out of a regular cup oh you saw
yeah yeah I say bro hey bro dice this
that's not your line that's not your
role we at the strip club that's not
what you say but you're not supposed to
be doing that wow that's intense I don't
want to know but wait so you you go
right to the strip club or you got three
hours you got somebody meeting there
then you go to meetings and then at the
word you run back to the strip club what
time you have to be back in the hotel
use like 11:30 so then you and how long
is that 7 o'clock meeting hour and a
half hour and a half
dudes are waiting burning rubber on the
way out in between Minnesota that's not
happenin many stars like us who see
what's going on in the movies yeah but
my Jack Frost's re-watch that cross but
even the Patriots you don't think that
come on man you don't think they come on
listen man I just assume all Patriots or
robots yeah right I just assumed that
like one shirt on the team he like
get-ups he not get it get up get out you
yeah yeah and he's like hey guys I'm
sure Randy with a cup I'm sure Randy was
chilling when he went down there sure
Chad Johnson was chilling when he went
back home in Miami right this is who has
of winning his record against the paper
the Dolphins yeah South Beach is a
[ __ ]
I just oh yeah I just assumed I don't
know dude I just forgot read you never
been down there
see basketball players cuz they get to
stay tonight so they play the game and
then they get to go to the club mark and
then they take it in the morning and
they got that's what I was wondering
when I went to whenever basketball team
came in Y Allen Iverson had a party
every place he was a head out the pardon
me yeah you don't even live here yo at
the party god bless Reebok for saving
him thirty-five million dollars from he
turns 50 bro he's it's the only reason
he's alive bro he's spending it
Oh already again right I hope not I was
in Atlanta laughs here's so many people
trying to take care of him I was in
Atlanta yeah you talk about the annuity
that John Thompson took yeah
bro I was it I was in Atlanta last week
I saw a I and two clubs getting in it I
know the thing is I grew up on I was
like like the reason that it took me a
long time to get into the shoe game is
everybody grew up on Jordans and I
[ __ ] grew up on Ivor Sam I resented
them first ones with the rare shooters
we read with the bottoms like I've
always thought those who bottoms on the
question reminded me of honey Concord
11s okay we're like that bottom
clearblue it's just the perfect bottom
but I [ __ ] love favorite color I I
loved the red gold and black zipper
because there was an era of the shoes
where Gary Payton Kobe and Iverson all
had zippers on their shoes and I loved
those I liked the RZA I still got a pair
other questions yeah they're phenomenal
but I always wanted to one of the green
tip oh those are like hard to get those
are pretty I was watching the game the
Michigan State Texas Tech game and Jason
Richardson had the Elevens with the
Hornet green on top and they look like
the classic Elevens they're so [ __ ] i
go to i go to flight climber everyone's
want to look at maybe the old school Ray
Allen Jordans yeah nobody my spin any
much damn money for the fucked-up thing
about flight club is when you you go up
there and it's like four hundred dollars
more than you thought it was gonna be
your but you don't know yeah you don't
look like a punk and you're like seven
hundred dollars for some [ __ ] air
attacks in three hours three dollars to
me but all right we already asked you
about the a/b juju
I just I'm trying to get in all the time
this is from Adam Koz can you please ask
if you remember having a confrontation
with Pat McAfee did you ever have one
the kicker
yeah I just had him on recently he's
[ __ ] hilarious a punter for the he
was on the Colts
did you ever have a I may have if I
wasn't supposed to it depends on what
year okay
it may have I mean I haven't fight
anybody I mean apparently they didn't I
was eager opportunities asking was there
ever a trash talker and this is gentle
man TBD he's a gentle man gentleman TVD
it says biggest trash talker coming
through during your draft year but was
there ever a trash talker that you guys
would get excited to face each other
because it would just go up was it like
Chad Johnson yeah yeah I got it
it's like a sport yeah yeah Chad Chad me
and Chad had a lengthy when we get off
the air I'll show you this little video
did this do it make for me that I didn't
realize that Chad was miked a lot and
you will see how you I'll show you how
you should treat Chad Johnson and then
man are you just going to come back
again because I have a lot of questions
my last one will be this from young Don
Farley ohm because I didn't really talk
about the can't wait thing but he
are you happy that you became a meme
with the interview of Sal it's it really
like when I search you on the Internet
goddamn it's the [ __ ] thing
that pops up all the time yeah yeah it's
gonna do something else I gotta like be
like ricochet and Denzel Washington
stand on top of the Empire State yet
waiters better be like I know that you
can't wait but we'll have it out in a
second yeah yeah it's all good man I
taking this try because you know what
when I'm in Baltimore though I don't get
any of that and it's weird because
that's they they see ya suggesting and
it is Jets and everybody else thing but
in Baltimore they see me as - Matt
backer so they see me Matt backer in
their shining moment it's like when I
killed Ben and when I threw the flag in
the stands for us those are the best
things there
which-which tenure did you enjoy the
most I would say to Ravens
yeah I'm really grateful well what a
[ __ ] special team to be a part of
right like every line every part you had
coaches that like knew what they were
doing it was like just think of what
they became
look at what Mike Smith had coach
Leslie Frazier yeah he was he was Louis
Marvin Lewis head coach Rex Ryan you
look at Mike Patton Rex Ryan Mike Nolan
Singletary like I was around some of the
smartest well not sing with her I was
wrong some great greatest football minds
ever Donnie Henderson Dennis Thurmond
like look I mean like people are talking
you know I remember I was talking to
eyes and I was just like hey people
always talk about this tree that tree
how about your trio right or the Brian
Billick tree and he always says that
history is the Bill Belichick tree so he
he cuz I was with him in Cleveland yeah
Ozzie considers him part of it so
whatever I don't give that to him I call
Ozzie his own tree
you know me is that much of a huh what
is he gonna do now that he's retired
oddly enough I think he's gonna probably
become an ad for Alabama oh that's
pretty good they still own I don't know
if his wife wants to go down there
because she its Alabama yeah I get it
but you know as he's always down there
he still owns a house on an island out
there - Wow any local billionaire loves
them all right so Amos Amos Amos Amos
owns everything done he's local
billionaire
those guys scare
[ __ ] out of me a masala stir root Chris
he owns all the restaurants 202 Senior
Bowl he owns the team yeah they'll do
this is the last one do banks 86 where
does Peyton Manning rank on talented
quarterbacks that you faced off against
I remember one Thursday night game as
the most entertaining game I've ever
seen it's when the Ravens defense was
operating on all cylinders Peyton
Manning was in his prime and I remember
I just remember Peyton at the line of
scrimmage and Ray at the line changing
back and forth if you want to see a
great chess match go back and watch the
year that the Colts won the Super Bowl
who was the best team in football the
Ravens the Steve McNair led ray Veilleux
thirteen and three Raven that was the
year I'm talking about yeah Peyton
Manning the great Peyton Manning 146
total yards that was a only time in my
life Rex lied to me he said you if you
don't give up a touchdown you can't lose
a football game Adam Adam Vinatieri five
field goals and y'all lost we lost we
picked Peyton off two times we destroyed
that was the greatest defensive game
we've ever played collectively but
Peyton Manning by far to me it's the
hardest opponent that I've ever had to
prepare for Brady does it with execution
Peyton does it we're putting so much
like mental stress on you it's like this
it's the burr twisty the football acumen
tests it's like going back and forth
you'll see when you play the Patriots
you know what they're doing
like first drive this is their concept
is how they're gonna try and beat us
they're gonna out execute you they're
gonna give you different formations
that's the same stuff yeah and other
people are gonna get in at different
times Peyton is like creating and
evolving before you right in front of
your eyes and it's like man what like
hold up coach
hold up you came to me in the first
quarter and you say yellow man left so
now he's playing left he's changed the
meaning of yellow in the middle of the
game so now yelling me something else so
now you like what you're learning and
Intel that you're trying to be a smart
football player he's using it against
you chase and his team understands what
he's doing and they're not messing up
where do you put him in terms of
quarterbacks of all time I mean you got
to go Brady now because just the
championship speak for themselves
yeah but he's definitely my top five
he's in my top five I have him out of
Murray know for sure
yeah and he's our error Moreno but he
won two I think he's I think he's
different than Moreno I think Reina he
was he was what Joan Johnny Unitas was
where Johnny came out there was like
calling the plays and I don't know if
we've even had anybody like that well
apparently Aaron Rodgers was calling his
own place apparently he was doing that
screw you McCarthy dummy go get a
massage dude I would do the same thing
disco double check all three but Peyton
was nice BJ ride you miss BJ ride you
just put it foot it foot I have heard a
lot of Green Bay Packers fans say that
BJ Raji not being there anymore he was
the guy that checked everybody in the
locker room he was a dirt
you need the funnyman jerk like we I
think you joke about this before like I
probably need a better friend to tell me
man you probably shouldn't wear that but
I don't know it just Dillon just still a
game yeah but like and we're with
Khalifa BJ Raji is the guy that said
shut the [ __ ] up
hey you need that guy on a team with you
gotta have him you guys you let those
egos fly free they'll take over the
whole team yeah appreciate you dude
oh good Bart Scott you up because you've
been coughing okay I get some mucinex I
was gonna say that yeah I'm flying too
[ __ ] much yeah these dirt balls on
[ __ ] play I'm just gonna end with
this I just think it's hilarious don't
get the measles people in first class
they got all this money they spend all
this money and they're eating [ __ ]
dog food yeah I'm loving it though I get
a [ __ ] cookie yeah anybody what you
want gross
Bart Scott Matt backer as always
bringing the heat appreciates you guys
as well I'm probably in Atlanta when
this podcast is coming out I will be
back draft is coming up we're gonna have
Josh Allen so and I said what's up I
will say hi I'm gonna see him in a Dave
& Buster's but yeah we're gonna have
Josh Allen later this week pass rusher
from Kentucky
check it out we'll be back see you guys